You might know that there's an annual
contest to implement the fastest sort.
Visit sortbenchmark.org for details.
If you didn't before, you now have
the chops to enter and kick butt.
Now, that sorting competition
focuses on disk-to-disk sorting.
But if you go read about the basic
schemes that different teams have used
over time, they're basically variants of
the sampling or the bucketing schemes.
And now that you've finished this
lesson, you know what that means.
Well, more or less, hopefully more.
As of September 2014 the fastest system
managed to sort seven
terabytes in a minute.
Now compare that to the first
year of the competition,
1995, when a team sorted just
over 1 GB of data in a minute.
That's a 7,000 fold improvement,
over 20 years, 7,000!
Think about that, that is [BLEEP] crazy!
Crazy!
That means that the amount of data you
can sort in a minute has doubled roughly
every 1.6 years which, curiously enough,
is right in line with Moore's law.